il avait toujours été naturellement très
pâle aphrodite ya saisi la tête qui s'en
va avec un bruit de soi qu'on déchire il
se proposait de la cacher chez elle sous
le sol de la cuisine peut être dans une
caverne d'hôtel seul avait le secret il
caressait ce débris en lui assurant
qu'ils étaient sauvés elle alla
s'asseoir sous le platane qui poussaient
en contrebas de la place dans le terrain
du fermier basile sous ses pieds et
rochers d'évoluer rapidement vers la
plaine il forêts tapissant la terre
faisaient de loin l'effet de mousse
minuscule tout au fond on apercevait la
mer entre deux lèvres de la montagne et
un frau dit ça se disait que si elle
avait pu décider costis à s'enfuir sur
ses vagues ne seraient pas obligées de
dodeliner en ce moment sur ses genoux
une tête strié de sang ces lamentations
contenu depuis l'origine de son malheur
et que la carte en sanglots véhément
comme ceux des pleureuses de funérailles
et les coudes et aux genoux les mains
appuyées contre ses joues humide laisser
couler ses larmes sur le visage du mort
ou la voleuse vague de prêtres qu'est ce
que tu fais dans mon verger le lieu
d'asile a remis d'une srp d'un bâton se
pencher au de la route et son air de
méfiance et de fureur ne parvenait
qu'elle rendre encore plus pareil un
épouvantail afro d'issia se leva d'un
bon couvrent la tête de son tablier
je ne t'ai voulait que peut donc le
bazile un peu d'ombré pour me rafraîchir
le front qu'est-ce que tu caches dans
ton habillé voleuse vaf de rien une
citrouille une patek
je suis pauvre oncle basile je ne t'ai
pris qu une pastèque bien rouge
rien qu'une passe
eq rouge avec des grains noirs au fond
montre moi ça menteuse espèce de taupe
noir et rend moins ce que tu m'as volé
le vieux base il s'engagea sur la pente
en brandissant son bâton aphrodisiaques
sont mis à courir
du côté du précipice tenant dans les
mains les points de son tablier
ils pendent devenait de plus en plus
rude le sentier de plus en plus glissant
comme si le centre du soleil prêt à se
coucher en avait poussé les pierres
depuis longtemps base il s'était arrêté
hurlait appelé nous voir pour avertir la
fuyarde de revenir en arrière
le sentier n'était plus qu'une piste et
la piste un éboulis de rochers afro dit
si elle entendait mais de ces paroles
déchiqueté par le vent elle ne
comprenait que la nécessité d'échapper
au village ou mensonge à la lourde
hypocrisie au long châtiment d'être jour
une vieille femme qui n'est plus aimé
une pierre enfin se détacha sous son
pied tomba au fond du précipice
comme pour lui montrer la route il avait
la fraude ici a plongé dans l'abîmé dans
le soir emportant avec elle la tête par
poyet de st